hey guys in this mkbhd video we'll be
taking a look at the apple wireless
keyboard both a hardware and software
impression from a windows user and also
as a side note if you give this video a
thumbs up as this video is for dave from
geekonites that would really help out a
lot so please like this video so without
any further ado let's take a look at the
review
so as with all apple packaging this one
is really really nice and simplified and
right when you take it out of the box
you pretty much know that you're messing
with apple hardware this one's no
exception you actually just get a nice
simple box with the keyboard itself
instructions and the warranty and the
two double the batteries that power the
sky are actually pre-installed in the
keyboard now as most of the mac users
watching this video probably already
know this is a bluetooth keyboard now
macs have bluetooth built in typically
but the pc i was testing this on my
desktop actually needed an external
bluetooth dongle which cost what 99
cents on amazon so just make sure you
have one of these before you get to
using it now the chiclet style keys and
the layout of this keyboard from above
is pretty much flawless it's the exact
same keyboard that you'll get when you
buy a macbook or a macbook pro and i
really don't have a problem with that i
do have pretty big hands but typing on
this has not been a problem at all but a
side note for windows users when you get
your drivers you'll actually get to
change the command button from command
to the windows key as this keyboard
doesn't have a windows key built in to
get a better idea of whether or not this
keyboard will actually work for you i
suggest you go into a store like a best
buy or something like that that carries
this keyboard and just type on it for a
little bit to see if it fits your hands
because you won't really like it if it
doesn't but i think the chicla style
keys will work for a wide variety of
people just fine so with all that kind
of boring stuff aside let's take a look
at the keyboard itself just the way it
looks is really really good apple does
that kind of stuff really well the form
factor of this keyboard is very very
thin and lightweight so i wouldn't have
a problem with throwing this in a laptop
bag and taking this with me if i had a
smaller laptop even the keys themselves
don't have a lot of travel as they are
the separated chiclet style so in the
end this hardware just is ridiculously
thin and this of course means it'll also
take up way less room on your desktop
now up on the top of the keyboard there
are a bunch of media controls and also
function keys that mac users probably
just love love love but that windows
users will have to do without so if
you're buying this keyboard and you get
the windows drivers unfortunately these
rarely include any functionality in
those top keys now for geeknights i'm
supposed to keep this video pretty short
but i just can't go without letting you
guys know that this keyboard is the
first really thin keyboard that i've
enjoyed a lot i've gone from a logitech
g19 and other thick chunky keyboards
like that to a nice thin chiclet style
keyboard and i really like this apple
keyboard for that reason so good job
apple with the form factor also this
keyboard has touted impressive battery
life i've had it for about a week which
isn't long enough to kill the battery
but it's so far so good also now that i
think about it the apple rechargeable
batteries probably make a really good
companion to this hardware so to
summarize and i know dave if you're
watching this you've probably had this
keyboard and can't empathize the pros
include an incredibly thin form factor a
decent battery life a range of function
keys and really good looks but this
keyboard is lacking in just a few areas
as i found that the size for big-handed
people possibly can be a potential
problem and pairing over bluetooth is
really hit-and-miss and also using it on
a pc leaves me wanting the full
experience mac os 10 here i come
i'm kidding either way this has been an
mkbhd video review of the apple keyboard
for the geek noids video contest be sure
to like it thanks for watching peace